all right ross we're going to dive in
with some delicious and decadent food
news
there it is oh i didn't hear it where's
sammy nom nom nom nom nom i'll do it for
her all right the new york post reports
a new study that scientifically found
out
hot chocolate makes you smarter hello
cheers to that
thank you and look we have some oh my
god last time you had hot cocoa
you know my daughter drinks it like all
the time and
i don't really like it to be perfectly
honest but i'm going to drink it up and
see if we get smarter
i haven't had it since i think it was
sixth grade and my report card came out
and my mom was like you got all bees
that's coco by the way better than i did
researchers at the university of i got
all studio 54s the university of
bringham
found that subjects were better and
faster at brain teasers after drinking
the hot cocoa because the compound
flavonol increases blood oxygenation
okay to the brain hot cocoa makes you go
go
go what do you think who knows all i'm
thinking about is studio 54 right now
that's what i'm thinking about oh baby
it was good
oh my god that's why i'm not like bummed
that my mom took me out i'm like what
else was i going to be doing and just
put on a bray as you said it did you
guys see that harder and drinking hot
cocoa
okay your turn uh last month oh this is
some sad news but
remember we lost canadian american
treasure alex trebek yeah rosie perez
and they were just talking about yeah
yeah we
my grandma my bunker we call her she's
94 and she watches jeopardy every single
night so this is really tough on her
uh he hosted for 36 years but now cnn
reports
the show will return this january with
an interim guest host ken jennings who
was the brainiac member who won like a
bazillion episode 74 games
in a row um people are saying he's the
perfect person to host in the in between
but i'm hearing drew that it could be
maybe anderson cooper
george stephanopoulos maybe and then how
about this as a replacement
oprah oh no can you picture it i know
she doesn't need to she'll need to do it
but wouldn't she be great
all i know is that i'm feeling smarter
by the sip and
um you know who i would think would make
an amazing
jeopardy host none other than gordon
ramsay who is just here he could tell
people to go hit the books
stop being an idiot and get smarter and
drink some cocoa
that would be hilarious to see him yell
at people if they get it wrong by the
way i'm not kidding i actually think
it's brilliant
i think so too gordon ramsay in jeopardy
i would watch that
you